1,2 hectare de terres arables par
habitant voilà ce qu'on a ici au canada
1,2 ha ça équivaut à peu près à deux
terrains de football américain
ça représente donc un immense potager
pour chaque canadien
c'est énorme c'est six fois plus que la
france 13 fois plus que la chine
mais est ce que ça veut dire pour autant
que notre sécurité alimentaire est
assurée selon l'organisation des nations
unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture la fao
le taux d'autosuffisance du canada
s'élève à 183 % ce qui veut dire qu'on
produit beaucoup plus de nourriture que
ce qu'on mange
en fait le canada est un champion de la
production alimentaire est un grand
exportateur de nourriture 75 % note bly
est exportée 70% notre port 95% nous
légumineuses donc a priori tout va bien
mais ce système là qui est en apparence
bien rodée et pourtant fragile est ce
qu'on produit massivement des céréales
et de la viande ne nous procure pas
exactement une diète équilibré ça c'est
l'hiver pas exactement des conditions
idéales pour pas pousser des fruits et
légumes ici justement au niveau des
fruits et légumes qu'on est le plus
dépendant mais ça n'a pas toujours été
le cas si on remonte dans le temps nos
arrière grands parents étaient
autosuffisants les fruits étaient manger
frais ou en confiture le reste de
l'année
certains légumes comme les pommes de
terre ou les navets se conserver pendant
d'helmand à la cave et d'autres étaient
mis en conserve évidemment il n'y avait
pas beaucoup de variété dans les
assiettes
une orange pour noël et des fruits
locaux en saison des fraises par exemple
ce père n'était pas en janvier
aujourd'hui leur rayon des fruits et
légumes est une explosion de couleurs et
l'exotisme 365 jours par année sont en
hiver 75% aux fruits et légumes viennent
de l'étranger est étonnamment même en
été aux dépens des autres pays pour
exporter
lui c'est dennis van winden il produit
des laitues beaucoup de l'étude
normalement elles sont vendues aux
usines qui approvisionne la restauration
rapide sur la côte est américaine mais
cette année c'est l'inconnu est-ce qu'on
va être capable de vendre six usines de
oui ou non
sinon on va se faire virer sur le marché
local par contre le marché la 13 sera
pas capable d'apprendre toute cette
quantité de l'étudiant constructive
pour le maraîcher c'est un vrai casse
tête au moment même où il doit planifier
les cultures à mettre en terre mais
notre dépendance envers l'étranger
il ne s'arrête pas là on se le cachera
pas travailler aux champs
c'est dur et depuis quelques années ça
se bouscule pas au portillon pour
planter désherber sarcler récolté au
canada il manque 60 mille travailleurs
agricoles
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on les fait
venir du mexique du guatemala de la
jamaïque
l'année dernière ils étaient 6000 dans
les fermes et les usines de
transformation québécoise mais quand les
frontières se ferment comme cette année
on se retrouve dans une position très
vulnérable
dennis van winden embauche près de 50
mexicain et certains travaillent chez
lui depuis plus de 20 ans la majorité
mam est déviée de trop loin de chez moi
alors c'est quoi le futur on voit avoir
à être être intelligent et à développer
des systèmes pour se sécuriser un peu et
mine de rien on est dépendant aussi des
rouages du système parce qu'au fil des
ans la production agricole s'est
spécialisée une ferme typique au début
des années 1960 avait des vaches
quelques cols des poules pour nourrir
les animaux on cultivait du foin et des
céréales
mais avec les années on a encouragé les
agriculteurs à se concentrer sur un
secteur de production par exemple alors
que la firme de 1960 comptait 19 corps
en moyenne aujourd'hui
un éleveur de porcs en a plus de 2300
faire du volume c'est souvent plus
rentable mais quand arrive un événement
comme la coved 19 cette machine la
montre ses failles
entre autres parce qu'il n'ya pas que
les firmes qui se sont spécialisés tout
le secteur des abattoirs aussi autrefois
on en comptait beaucoup un peu partout
sur le territoire
mais aujourd'hui 95 % de la viande
canadienne est transformée dans
d'immenses usines
quand un seul de ces lieux la ferme
temporairement s'entraîne tragique effet
domino les éleveurs le savent plus quoi
faire de leurs bêtes
au québec près de 100000 port pourrait
être euthanasié à cause du
ralentissement dans les usines de
transformation du halak au vide 19 des
ports dont les carcasses risque de ne
pas être transformés en viande mais en
nourriture pour chiens et chats
evans fraser et spécialiste de la
sécurité alimentaire à l'université de
guelph en ontario
il se questionne beaucoup sur les
chaînes d'approvisionnement ici au
canada et ailleurs dans le monde
[Musique]
avant la crise et toutes les pertes
d'emplois plus 4 millions de canadiens
étaient déjà en situation d'insécurité
alimentaire ça représente un ménage sur
huit donc sur le plan logistique notre
système basé sur les exportations les
importations massives fonctionne on n'a
pas vraiment vu de tablettes vide
pendant la cueillette 19 mai il laisse
sur leur faim
un grand nombre de canadiens peut-être
faudra-t-il donc prendre un peu de recul
et se demander comment rendre la
nourriture plus accessible
pensez à nous nourrir d'abord nous mêmes
et à toute petite échelle on peut
profiter du printemps pour se faire un
mini potager pour devenir autosuffisants
mais pour mieux comprendre d'où vient
une partie de ce qu'on mange et tout le
travail qu'il ya derrière
[Musique]